let me explain to you why i say that uh
you know 23 is the is women's sexual
market value peak years okay
would you please define
that term exactly i will okay there's a
reason why they call the store forever
21 and not forever 41. okay
there's a reason for it
really
very vile
it's very vile but it's very vile
because it exposes you to the raw nature
of the sexual marketplace right now
which more and more people are going to
be exposed to as we since we have the
internet since we have access to this
information right now and the
information is this is that if you go
and you look at i think i quoted a data
clasm from i forget the guy who is the
founder of okcupid but we have data sets
right now that will show that um when
when men are polled
what do they find them what age do they
find women the most attractive from 15
all the way to 95 they all say right
around 22 23 24 years old every single
one of them so at all age cohorts so
when we're looking at women when women
say well what age do you find men the
most attractive if that woman is say 30
years old that guy's usually somewhere
between 33 and 37 years old it's like a
three to seven depending on how you know
it staggers up for that woman so that
woman is always looking for a guy and
this is in the long term like
long-term you know perspective if that
woman is 20 she's looking for a guy
who's between 23 and 27 years old going
and staggering up depending on what her
particular needs are at that particular
time which change over the course of a
woman's maturity when she's 18 to 28 i
was as i was saying before there are
different priorities for what she's
looking for she's looking for the hot
guy in the foam cannon party in spring
break in cancun when she's 18 to 28 but
when she gets to 29 that's when she says
you know what maybe it would be great to
go and have babies now or settle down
and have have something that's a little
bit more long-term
unfortunately in our society today we
encourage the idea that women have can
be their their sexual market value is
evergreen and anything we can sell that
t that that impresses that upon women
they will buy into that so when we're
looking at like freezing your eggs when
we look at um you know fine
whatever it is provide your own security
through your profession through your
education whatever because you can't
trust a guy to do that so you have to do
it yourself
that when you get to 29 to 33 years old
31 years old you get into this epiphany
phase where you're like oh
i i don't i'm done with those jerks i'm
done with the hot guys that i was with
back in my 18 to 28 hours i'm not done
yet maybe you're not you're not done
with that
and again
okay are you currently in your whole
face no statistically speaking relax bro
the average age of first marriage in the
united states is
29.7 or something like that at the age
it's almost 30 years old for women it's
like 28 or 29 somewhere around so that
means 29 year olds are married
exactly where you're at right now could
you see yourself being with a guy
exactly your age
um yeah like sometimes i've thought
about that i would like to be with
someone my age we can like grow old
together or i could be with someone
younger so i die first
you